SEPTEMBER SIXTH HEARING OF THE
JOINT COMMITTEE ON RULES IS
HEREBY CALLED ORDER I WANT TO
WELCOME EVERYONE AND THANKS FOR
JOINING THIS SIX HEARING OF THE
SENATE ASSEMBLY JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE TOPIC OF OUR
CAPITAL IN THIS PROJECT. AND WE
HAVE JUST A LIMITED TIME THIS
MORNING WITH ALL THE OTHER WORK
TO WILL PROCEED IN THE BUILDING
THE STATE. SO I WANT TO NOTE
THAT THROUGHOUT TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH OUR FIRST
HEARING. BEFORE THIS PANEL ON
JULY SIXTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN. OUR COMMITTEE
AND ARSON ASSEMBLY STAFF HAVE
BEEN VERY ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
FACT FINDING HEARINGS AND
STUDIES. THAT HAVE LED TO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE ANNEX
PROJECT OVERVIEW AND SEQUENCE
REPORT. POS SUPPORT WHICH IS
BEFORE US TODAY TODAY'S ACTION
ALSO REFLECTS WERE CONDUCTED
PURSUANT TO A FORMAL MEMORANDUM
OF UNDERSTANDING. THIS WAS THE
PRODUCT OF LONG DIALOGUE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION GOVERNOR
BROWN THROUGHOUT TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. AND WAS FORMALLY
EXECUTED ON THE MORNING OF
NOVEMBER NINTH TWENTY EIGHTEEN.
SO THE PROJECTS OF REMOVING FOR
WE'VE HAD OUR- OUR TEAM WORKING
ON IT. AND IT IS PRECEDED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE. OF THE PRIOR
ADMINISTRATION AS WELL AS THE
CURRENT ADMINISTRATION. AND OF
COURSE WITH OUR LEADERSHIP DO
HOUSES SO THIS AND INCLUDES.
DEBRA GRAVERT. WHO IS BIN AND
DISPOSE JUST OF LATELY A LOPEZ
HER DEPUTY. AND MISTER OLIVAREZ
IN HIS FORMER ROLE CONTINUING
NOW I'LL WORK WITH SECTOR THE
SENATE ERICA CONTROLLERS WHOSE
WITH THIS IS BORING SO I THANK
YOU FOR JOINING US MADAM
SECRETARY. SO WITH THAT I JUST
WELCOME YOU ALL HERE AND I
OFFER MY VICE CHAIR REMARKS WE
WILL PROCEED. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR JUST BRIEFLY I WANNA. ADD
MY THANKS TO YOU AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND IN YOUR
TEAM I WANT TO THANK ALL THE-
COLLABORATORS WHO ARE GATHERED
HERE THIS MORNING IN THOSE WHO
HAVE BEEN HELPING TO PUSH THIS
FORWARD ON STRICT TIMELINE SO.
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING THE
PRESENTATION AND AGAIN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. SO AT THIS TIME
WILL PROCEED ITEM TO OUR
AGENDA. OVERVIEW THE
RECOMMENDED PROJECT OVER IN
SECRET SUPPORT PLAN. AND I WILL
ASK A CENTER HERTZBERG MY
PARTNER IN THE SENATE ON THIS.
TO JOIN TO PROCEED IN. PROVIDE
SOME OVERVIEW COMMENTS ON THE
CENTER HERTZBERG. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND. YOU KNOW
I'VE BEEN IN THIS BUSINESS FOR
A LONG TIME AND. I DON'T THINK
I'VE EVER MET ANYBODY WHO'S
BEEN SO COMMITTED TO A PROJECT
LIKE THIS AS YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN. SPEAKING EVERY DAY
OVER THE WEEKEND LOSE AND
SLEEPLESS NIGHTS WHETHER ONE
AGREES OR DISAGREES WITH YOU
KNOW WHEN CAN WALK AWAY WITH
THE IMPRESSION THAT THIS IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT YOU SEE THE
EXTRAORDINARY HISTORIC VALUE
IN. AND ARE TAKING THIS
SERIOUSLY THIS ISN'T JUST ONE
OF YOUR MANY PROJECTS IT IS
YOUR MOST IMPORTANT PROJECT AND
I GIVE YOU A GREAT DEAL OF
RESPECT FOR THAT. BECAUSE IT IS
IMPORTANT THAT WE ARE NOT
BUILDING FOR A ALTHOUGH THIS IS
SCHEDULED TO THE ANNEX TO BE
DONE IN TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE'RE BUILDING FOR. TWENTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE AND TWENTY TO
TWENTY FIVE THIS IS ABOUT THE
FUTURE. IN SO GIVEN THE
TRUNCATED TIME THIS MORNING
BECAUSE OF THE COMPETING
SCHEDULES THAT WE HAVE WHAT WE
HAVE YOUR BEFORE MR HEART'S
GOING TO TALK ABOUT IS THIS
ORDER THIS IS MORE THAN A
YEAR'S WORTH OF WORK.
CONSULTING WITH AS MANY PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET GATHER AS MANY
POINTS OF VIEW ALL INFORMED BY
A BIG PICTURE THINK. ARM AND
GUIDED BY ON I WOULD SAY THE
SECOND PERSON IS PUT THE MOST
AMOUNT OF TIME IN THIS IS DIANE
BOYD IRVINE WHO NOT IT WAS HAD
TO DEAL WITH JUST EXTRAORDINARY
DETAILS IN MODERN TIMES. YOU
CAN'T JUST GO AND BUILD A
BUILDING LIKE HE'S DO BEFORE
THE LEGAL RESTRICTIONS THE
BIDDING PROCESSES THE
INTERVIEWS IS STRICTLY
CONTROLLED THE CONTRACTS THE
LEGISLATIVE WORK IS NOTHING
LESS AN EXTRAORDINARY AND SO I
THINK THAT. THIS IS A VERY BIG
DEAL AND WHAT WHAT INSPIRES ME
FOUND THIS ALTHOUGH I DON'T
AGREE WITH EVERYTHING ALL THE
TIME AND I PUSH AS HARD AS I
CAN IT'S THOSE WHO'VE BEEN
AROUND THE TABLE WITH ME NOW.
BUT BUT I THINK THAT THE
SERIOUSNESS OF PURPOSE WITH
WHICH EVERYONE HAS TAKEN THIS
THE HISTORIC SENSE OF LONG TERM
VIEW THINKING LONG INSTEAD OF
THE IMMEDIACY. I THINK IS THE
BIGGEST PART OF THIS THIS.
LARGER DYNAMIC GOOD THIS
DOCUMENT TALKS ABOUT DELIVERY
METHODS AND DATES AND
PROCUREMENT. IN ALL OF THE MEAT
AND POTATOES WHICH IS NECESSARY
AT THIS STAGE BEFORE WE MOVE
ON. WITH THE ANNEX PROJECT AND
I. I JUST THE BOTTOM LINE IS IT
IS THAT IT IT IS A VERY GOOD
JOB. STILL ALWAYS A WORK IN
PROGRESS AS WE CONTINUE TO
LEARN AND GROW AND LISTEN. BUT
I END WITH THE POINT THAT I
STARTED WITH ABOUT THINKING
BIG. IN UNDERSTANDING THE NEW
TRENDS ABOUT WHERE THINGS ARE
GOING AND TRY TO MAKE SURE IS
THIS CAPITAL AND BODIES THE
IMAGINATION AND GREATNESS.
WHICH INSPIRES PEOPLE FROM
EVERY CORNER OF THIS PLANET TO
FALL IN LOVE WITH CALIFORNIA.
VERY GOOD. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TO HER AND I WANTED KNOWLEDGE
HE HAS MUCH MORE OF A PERSONAL
BACKGROUND. IN LARGE
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS OF ALL
MANNER OF THINGS HIS LAW
PRACTICE HIS DECADES OF PUBLIC
LEADERSHIP CIVIC LEADERSHIP.
AND THAT HAS BEEN AN
INDISPENSABLE PART OF THIS
PROCESS BECAUSE HE DOES TO ASK
QUESTIONS THAT. OPEN THINGS UP
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT
I ALSO WANT TO KNOW WE HAVE
REPRESENTS OF THE CAPITOL
HISTORICAL COMMISSION HERE
TODAY MISTER DICK CALLANAN CORN
BUT RIGHT THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US IN THIS MEETING. SHORT ACT
OF WILL TURN OUT TO THE
PRESENTATION OF THE PROJECT
OVER IN SECRET SUPPORT BY
MISTER HART AND WE ARE
APPROACHING OUR QUORUM SO AT
THE POINT THAT WE HAVE A QUORUM
MY WILL INTERRUPT TO MR HARDEN
JUST JUST UPS THE QUORUM FOR
PERSONAL DUTY DOING BUSINESS.
AND RECOGNITION THAT WE ARE
PERCEIVED AS A SUBCOMMITTEE OF
COURSE. CHECK OUT MISTER CHAIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'D APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
TODAY TO. KIND OF REVIEW WITH
YOU THE OVERVIEW IN SEQUENCE
REPORT. THIS LAST WEEK ON
FRIDAY WE FINALIZE THIS AND
SENT THIS OUT TO ALL OF YOU AND
SO YOU. HAD SHOULD HAVE
RECEIVED IT IN YOUR OFFICE ON
FRIDAY OF THE LAST OF LAST WEEK
SO HOPEFULLY YOU'VE- HAD SOME
OPPORTUNITIES AND SOMETIME THIS
WEEK TO TAKE A LOOK AT IT. THE
WAY THAT DOCUMENT IS ORGANIZED
IS THAT SECTION ONE. IS A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF THE PROJECT TO THAT
GIVES YOU SOME OF THE GENERAL
DESCRIPTIONS GENERAL OUTLINE OF
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH
AND SOME OF THE THINGS WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT. SECTIONS TWO
AND THREE. ARE THE PORTIONS OF
THE DOCUMENT THAT WILL BE
AMENDED INTO THE YOU WHEN THAT
IS DONE. IN THE IN THE FUTURE.
THE FIRST THE SECTIONS GO
THROUGH AND THEY TALK ABOUT THE
SCOPE BUDGET DELIVERY METHODS
AND SCHEDULE. OF EACH ELEMENT
OF THE PROJECT IT GIVES SOME
OVERVIEW AND DEFINITION TO THE
PROJECTS. IT TALKS A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT HOW AND WHERE AND WHY.
THESE THINGS THE PROJECTS WILL
BE THE BILL. SECTIONS FOR TO
SECTION SEVENTEEN. COVER THE
GUIDING PRINCIPLES IN THE IN
THE DOCUMENT YOU WILL NOTICE
THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED SEVERAL
KEY. PRINCIPLES THAT THIS
PROJECT WILL BE DESIGNED AROUND
AND THOSE ARE IN SECTION FIVE
SECTION SIX COVERS. THE
GUIDELINES IMPERATIVES AND
WE'VE PROVIDED A LIST OF
GUIDELINES THOSE ARE CONTAINED
IN A SEPARATE DOCUMENT THAT IS
A DOCUMENT THAT WE WILL USE TO
WORK WITH THE- ARCHITECTS
ENGINEERS AND CONTRACTORS TO
CONVEY THOSE THINGS THAT ARE
MOST IMPORTANT. SECTION SEVEN
IS THE CAPITAL SITE AND TREE
PLAN AND THIS OUTLINES THE
METHOD IN WHICH WE ARE
ANTICIPATING WORKING WITH AND
AROUND THE TREES AND ON THE
SITE. SECTION EIGHT ARE SOME
DESIGN OPTIONS WITH A
RECOMMENDED OPTION FOR EACH ONE
OF THE THREE THAT WE HAVE
PROVIDED. SECTION NINE IS A
HIGH LEVEL SPACE PLAN THIS IS A
PLAN THAT HAS BEEN. DEVELOPED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS
IT WAS FIRST BEGUN. WHEN MR
COOLEY CHAIRMAN COOLEY. DEVELOP
THE BLUE BOOK THAT YOU HAVE ALL
SEEN. BY C. S. H. Q. A AND WE
HAVE TAKEN THAT PROGRAM AND
MODIFIED IT A LITTLE BIT AND
PROVIDED THAT WITHIN THE
DOCUMENT. WE THEN HAVE A
SECTION TEN ON PRESERVATION AND
SYMBOLISM. AND THEN BUILDING
SYSTEMS WE TALK ABOUT THE
MECHANICAL SYSTEMS ELECTRICAL
SYSTEMS THE STRUCTURAL SYSTEMS.
AND WE'VE INCLUDED IN THERE A
SYSTEM THAT WE CALL MOVABLE
WALL SYSTEMS ARE DEMOUNTABLE
WALLS AND THE REASON FOR THAT
IS WE REALIZED THAT YOU GO
THROUGH A LOT OF CHANGE. AND SO
WE'RE TRYING TO THINK ABOUT HOW
WE MIGHT WANT TO HANDLE THAT IN
THE FUTURE. WE THEN TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT SECTION OF THE
SEQUENCE OF THE WORK AND THERE
IS A- SECTION IN THERE THAT HAS.
BUT DENNIS SIZE YEAR BY YEAR
THE DIFFERENT TASKS IN THE
DIFFERENT RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT. WE WILL BE NEEDING TO
FULFILL AND MEET IN ABLE IN
ORDER TO KEEP THE PROJECT ON
SCHEDULE IN AND ON BUDGET. WE
THEN HAVE A DISCUSSION ON IN
SECTION THIRTEEN ABOUT
PROCUREMENT DELIVERY METHOD I'M
IN A ROCK YOU BET. WE WERE
STEPS ARE QUORUM SOLD MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY HERE
CALDERON CARILLO CUNNINGHAM
FLORA GRAYSON. KAMLAGER-DOVE
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RIVAS WALDRON WICKS
SENATOR MONNING HERE. SORRY
SPEAKER RENDON EXCUSE ME ATKINS
BATES. HERTZBERG HELLO LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL HERE MORE LOCK.
NIELSEN. ROTH SKINNER NUMBER
WIENER. WILK RIVAS. WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO I'M GONNA TURN IT
BACK TO MISTER HART I DO WANT
TO JUST EXPLAIN TO THE MY
COLLEAGUES ON THE COMMITTEE AND
WHAT YOU'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE A
PER HEARINGS. WE ARRIVED AT. WE
CAN YOU MISTER HART. IN THE IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN I
RESET THE NATIONAL COUNCIL
STATE LEGISLATORS. ASKING THEM
FOR INFORMATION FROM OTHER
STATES. CONCERNING WHO HAD
WORKED ON STATE CAPITALS.
LOOKING FOR THAT PARTICULAR
SKILL SET. NCSL IN ABOUT. A DAY
OR TWO GOT BACK WITH THIS WITH.
THE COMMITTEE MISTER HART OF
MOCHA. HE WAS INVOLVED THE
REBUILD UTAH STATE CAPITOL ON
BUDGET ON TIME. MINNESOTA
REBUILD ON BUDGET ON TIME. IN
WYOMING WHICH WAS JUST OPENED
ON THE SCHEDULE HE SAID. THERE
ARE FIFTY MILLION IN THE HOLE
AND HE WAS BROUGHT IN A KIND OF
BAIL PROJECT OUT. AND HIS
TIMING TARGET BROUGHT INTO LINE.
NONE THE LESS WE WORK WITH HIM
FOR THAT FIRST JUNE AND JULY
SIX THAT WAS SORT OF A CHANCE
TO TAKE A TEMPERATURE ON.
MISTER HART JUST GET SOME
ACQUAINTANCE WITH HIM WITHIN
RETAINED IN TO ASSIST US LAST
YEAR WORK WITH THE BROWN
ADMINISTRATION THE MOVE YOU.
WHICH WAS ALSO A VERY POSITIVE
EXPERIENCE AT A CHANCE TO GET
TO KNOW AND- SO WE HAVE
RETAINED HIM TO PERFORM HIS
WORK ON OUR BEHALF FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S BEHALF. HERE IN
CALIFORNIA SO WITH THAT I'LL
LET YOU. BRISKLY CONCLUDE
INSURABLE PERCY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN. WE WERE JUST
GOING THROUGH THE DIFFERENT
SECTIONS SECTION FOURTEEN IS
THE BUDGET WE HAVE GONE THROUGH
AND DONE A AN ANALYSIS OF THE
BUDGET AND THE ANALYSIS OF THE-
GUIDELINES IN THE SCOPE. THAT
HAS BEEN ATTENTIVE FIGHT IN THE
DOCUMENT AND WE PUT A PRICE TO
THAT. WE BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
WITHIN THE BUDGET PARAMETERS.
THE SECTION FIFTEEN IS THE
SCHEDULE THAT HAS GONE THROUGH
AND TRY TO IDENTIFY THE USE OF
UTILIZING THE DIFFERENT
DELIVERY METHODS. HOW THE
PROJECT WILL UNFOLD IN AND WE
SHOW THAT WE ARE ABLE TO
COMPLETE THAT. BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THERE IS A SECTION ON
GOVERNANCE AND STEWARDSHIP THAT
WE HAVE INCLUDED AND THEN SOME
REFERENCES. AND THE FINAL
SECTION IS A SECTION ON TEST
FIT STUDIES AND WITHIN THE
DOCUMENT PRESENTLY THERE IS A-
SECTION THAT DEMONSTRATES HOW
THE VISITOR CENTER MAY BE DONE.
AGAIN THIS IS NOT A DESIGN IT
IS A TAKING THE ELEMENTS OF THE-
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE IDENTIFIED
WE HAVE THEN GONE AHEAD AND
LAID SOMETHING OUT SHOWING HOW
IT MAY BE ACCOMPLISHED. WE'RE
IN THE PROCESS OF HIRING
ARCHITECTS AND ENGINEERS AND
CONTRACTORS WHO HELPED. PUT
THAT TOGETHER. AND THEN WITH
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN. I WILL
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS IF THERE
ARE ANY. POLITICS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MISTER HART TO
SPORTING. AS WE- SEEING NONE I
WILL INVITE WILL TURN OUT TO
PUBLIC COMMENT AND I KNOW A%
MISTER COUNTY WANT TO COME DID
YOU WISH TO COME UP AND OFFER
SOME REMARKS. THE ACCOUNT OF
THE CALIFORNIA CAPITOL
HISTORICAL COMMISSION. EVERYONE
HAS TO RUN ANOTHER ROOM AT
EIGHT THIRTY SO GOOD MORNING.
I'M RICHARD CAL AND I'M THE ONE
OF THE SENATE APPOINTEES TO
YOUR HISTORIC STATE CAPITOL
COMMISSION CONGRATULATIONS MR
COOLEY AND MEMBERS OF THE- A
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE ON A
PROJECT WELL BEGUN IN WELL
UNDER WAY. I ENJOYED MISTER
HERTZBERG'S COMMENTS ABOUT
THINKING LONG TERM ON THIS
PROJECT MR COOLEY AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION THIS MORNING AMONG
THE THINGS THAT COULD BE WORKED
LONG TERM AND I HOPE IS. IS OUR
CAPITAL PARK MASTER PLAN HOW
WILL WE GOVERN CAN PLAN FOR THE
PARK. IT IS A HUNDRED YEAR
QUESTION. WE ENJOYED BEING A
STAFF TO THE LEGISLATURE AND
INVITE YOU TO INVOLVE US IN
QUESTIONS IF YOU HAVE THEM AND
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THIS
MORNING CONGRATULATIONS. THANK
OU VERY MUCH MISTER COLLINS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LONG
DEVOTION TO THE PROJECT. IS
THERE ANY OTHER PUBLIC COMMENT
THIS MORNING. HEARING NONE WE
NOW TURN TO THE BUSINESS
PORTION OF THE MEETING AND I
WILL TURN TO WE HAVE THE
RECOMMENDATION FOR THE ADOPTION
OF THE P. O. S. REPORT. AND
THAT RECOMMENDATION COMES FROM
THE EXECUTIVE COMMITTEE WHICH
WAS FORMED IN THE AMMO YOU
SIGNED LAST FALL. AND CEDAR ON
THAT EXACTLY COMMITTEES ERIN
SURE THE GUY WAS DIRECTOR OF
OPERATIONS CENTER HERTZBERG ON
HALF THE SENATE MYSELF. SO WE
HAVE BEEN DOWN IN THE DETAILS
OF THIS POS REPORT. WE BRING IT
FORWARD WITH THE RECOMMENDATION
ADOPTION SO IS THERE A MOTION
ON. MONEY THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS I WOULD MOVE THE
JOINT RULES COMMITTEE ADOPT THE
PROJECT OVERVIEW IN SEQUENCE
POS REPORT AS PRESENTED TODAY
IN THIS IT MAY INCORPORATE ANY
AMENDMENTS APPROVED BY THE
ANNEX PROJECT EXECUTIVE
COMMITTEE AS PART OF THIS
MOTION THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE FORMALLY REQUESTS
THAT SECTION TWO OF THE POS
DESIGNATED EXECUTIVE SUMMARY IN
SECTION THREE OF THE P. O. S.
DESIGNATED PROJECT DEFINITION
SHOULD BE INCORPORATED AS AN
AMENDMENT INTO THE ANNEX
PROJECT MEMORANDUM OF
UNDERSTANDING ENTERED INTO THE
NINTH DAY OF NOVEMBER. TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THE SERVER NIELSEN HONOR TO
SECOND THE MOTION. VERY GOOD WE
HAD A IT HAS BEEN MOVED AND
SECONDED IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THAT MOTION.
SERVER MORLOCK. YES PLEASE TAKE
THE CHRISTIAN CHURCH ON ON THE
BUDGET ESTIMATES SECTION
FORTUNATE WE STILL. HERE IF WE
ARE JUST WHAT IS THE TOTAL COST
THAT. IS SUMMARY FOR MY MISSING
IT. SO THE WE CAN'T SEE IT ON
THE BUDGET WE ARE ABOUT THE
WORLD. I REMEMBER WHAT THE
NUMBER IS WE'RE UNDER THE SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE FIVE FIFTY NINE
NUMBER BY ROUGHLY TWENTY TO
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. YOU
CAN'T GET MORE PRECISE. SO WILL
BE AT A TOTAL COST ABOUT SEVEN
FIFTY FIVE YEAH ABOUT THREE
QUARTERS OF A BILLION THAT'S
CORRECT YES WHICH IS THE BUDGET
WE WERE. GIVEN TO WORK WITH
THANK YOU THANK YOU. VERY GOOD.
CHOOSING THIS IS THE RESULT OF
THE PROJECT ESTIMATE IS FOR.
THE ANNEX BUILDING IN CHIEF.
FOR A VISITOR CENTER AND FOR
REVISED PARKING SO WE NO LONGER
HAVE PARK IN EARLY TO BUILDING
INCORPORATE YOUR IDEA OF
BUILDING THE PARKING SPACE SUCH
THAT IF IN THE FUTURE. WE ARE
NO LONGER USING CARS OR HAVE
THE NEED FOR AS MANY VEHICLES
THE COULD BE CONVERTIBLE OFFICE
SPACE. THE SWING SPACE BUILDING
IS BEING. BUILT UNDER TGS
DIRECTION AND THEY HAVE A
DIFFERENT FINANCING. SO THAT
NUMBER REFLECTS THE COST TO
THOSE THREE ELEMENTS ESTIMATED
BY TGS IN MARCH OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WITH A ESCALATION UP
THROUGH JANUARY FIRST OF.
TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN IT THE YES
CORRECT THE ESCALATION IS TO
THE SIGNING OF THE GMP AND THEN
WE'VE GOT THE 20% OF IT
ESCALATED TO THE MID POINT OF
CONSTRUCTION. YES. OKAY OKAY
VERY GOOD OKAY OF THEN LET'S
CALL THE ROLL I INTEND TO RIVER
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
REGIONAL TRYING TO ACCOMMODATE
COLLEAGUES WHO WOULD ARRIVE. TO
ON THE MOTION ASSEMBLYMEMBER
COOLEY HI COOLEY I'D CALDERON
CARILLO CARILLO AYE A
CUNNINGHAM FLORA FLORA AYE
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE. KAMLAGER-DOVE I
AM MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MATHIS
AYE QUIRK SILVA. QUIRK SILVA I
RAMOS RAMOS I RIVAS. RIVAS AYE
WALDRON WICKS MISTER SPEAKER
SENATOR MONNING. CENTER MONNING
AYE ATKINS BATES BATES AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG AYE
HILL HILL AYE LEYVA. MCGUIRE
MITCHELL. MITCHELL I MORE A LOT
MORE LOCK AYE NIELSEN AYE
WIENER. WIENER AYE WILK. OKAY
SO THE CURRENT. OKAY WE IS NINE
AND EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES I
WILL REMAIN BECAUSE WE HAVE
SOME CALLERS WHO YET SO I'LL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FULL BIT
BUT THAT MEASURE IS PASSED AND
I THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION IN THIS. HISTORIC
DAY. YEAH OKAY THANK YOU THANK
.
YEAH YEAH OKAY. THEY GO. COURSE
YES LEAVE A REPLY YEAH. THAT'S
ALL I NEED OKAY YEAH OR SHOULD
IT
. YEAH
. WHAT ARE YOU
. BOARD
CENTER WALKING
. YEAH BORING
LONG. WE JUST HAD THE ONE
MOTION ONE RAN SEND MOTION SO
YOU SAY YOU ARE. NO NO PROBLEM
YEAH OH GOSH OKAY NO PROBLEM SO
I AM CONSENT PERFECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SO IT WILL YOU KNOW
.
OKAY. IN THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE ME THIS MORNING I AM
PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE-
MOTION BY SENATOR BILL MONEY IN
MOVING ADOPTION DEPUIS REPORT.
AND A REQUESTING THAT CHAPTERS
TWO AND THREE BE AMENDED INTO
THE M. O. U. OF. NOVEMBER NINTH
TWENTY EIGHTEEN WAS APPROVED
UNANIMOUSLY ON A VOTE OF TWENTY
TWO TWO ZERO THIS MORNING AND
THIS MEETING OF THE JOINT RULES
COMMITTEE IS HEREBY ADJOURNED
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
VERY. ALRIGHT ACTUALLY TO TAKE
WHATEVER YOU'RE USING